when we talk about contemporary turkey
we think of the longer career of the
current president erdogan but we will
come slowly to talk about his politics
first a little geography which never
hurts we are dealing with a nation in
the middle between southeastern europe
and western asia divided into two
peninsula regions eastern thrace and
anatolia border to the north west by
greece and bulgaria to the south by
syria and iraq and to the east by iran
armenia and georgia thanks to its
strategic location the country has
positioned itself as a bridge between
different cultures benefiting from
democratic influences from the old
continent and becoming a role model for
all middle eastern countries aspiring to
a synthesis of islam and the rule of law
now we are witnessing a reversal and the
recent authoritarian drift has greatly
slowed down the process of establishing
democratic principles we can say that
the beginning of these processes dates
back to the late 19th century when
competition with european powers led
some of the cultural elites within the
ottoman empire to push for modernization
a goal that according to some could be
achieved by maintaining a synthesis
between islamic faith and state
institutions but which according to
others including the famous mustafa
kemal required a clean break between
state and religion which had to be
limited to the private sphere of the
citizen after the 1923 elections that
saw the victory of the republican
people's party led by ataturk turkish
became the official language in place of
arabic the form of state was revised in
a republican key a head of state and the
prime minister appointed by the head of
state were established then within the
following year to solve the problem of
the difficult coexistence between
democracy and islam islam was erased
from the country's daily life by
abolishing the sultanate caliphate and
islamic courts this wasn't such a clean
exit however since despite the forced
secularization sunni islam continued to
remain very deeply rooted especially
among the rural and less educated
population also thanks to the influence
that religious brotherhoods have always
exerted on every aspect of society these
include the south oriented noxibendi to
which netmetinir bakan erdogan's
political father belonged and the his
met founded by fethullah gulen which
erdogan used to rise to power and with
which he came into open conflict during
the attempted cope of 2016. however what
were the highlights of the kemalist
reforms with the establishment of the
republic of turkey on october 29 1923
legislative and executive powers passed
into the hands of the assembly which was
responsible for electing the president
of the republic the head of the seoul
party for four-year terms the head of
state in turn appointed the president of
the council of ministers and the members
of the council itself completing the
picture where the stated independence of
the judiciary the recognition of the
formal equality of citizens before the
law and the granting of the active and
passive vote to women a milestone
achieved in 1934 long before several
european countries but it was in 1937
that the most important constitutional
reform took place the one that defined
the so-called six arrows of the turkish
state republican nationalist populist
statist reformist and secular ataturk's
death in 1938 and the shift from single
party to multiple political formations
caused by a number of adverse
circumstances including economic
backwardness compared to the west were
two of the main reasons that prevented
full democratic transition as the years
passed there was the emergence of more
liberal currents promoting private
initiative that met with the support of
the dissatisfied middle class and less
literate rural classes among these
gaining the most support was adnan
mender's democrat party which in the
1950 elections succeeded denouncing the
old single party and demolishing the
pillars of chemism measures such as the
call to prayer in arabic the opening of
many mosques and reading via state radio
of passages from the koran would allow
religious values to re-emerge in
contrast to the previous statist vision
the situation is also very similar in
contemporary turkey on the one hand the
aspiration for a secular and democratic
society as stated in the constitution
but on the other hand a deeply religious
society that struggles to recognize
itself in national democratic
institutions despite the new
government's good achievements including
membership in the international monetary
fund openness to both the west and arab
countries and decent economic growth
social tensions simmering in the
background erupted in the famous
istanbul pogrom of 1955 when a
right-wing nationalist group clashed
with a greek minority present in the
city's suburbs resulting in the deaths
of 30 people mandarin's party was
accused of taking an authoritarian turn
and planning the pogrom despite its
declared democratic openness so to
restore order and prevent a religious
drift in the country the army as the
guardian of the constitution seized the
power by force on may 27 1960. this date
frames the first of four military coups
in the period between 1960 and 1997
during which the secular organs of the
state represented by the military
several times came face to face against
the confessional parties
an important step is found in the second
coup of 1971 but especially the third in
1980 because they served to inaugurate
the so-called turkish islamic synthesis
that is the fusion of kemalism and sunni
islam in essence the military in order
to prevent the secularity of the state
from being compromised decided to come
to an agreement with the islamic
components of society becoming the
bridge for islam to officially penetrate
the institutions long story short in the
80s this was the situation after the
coup was over a consulting assembly
formed by the supreme military organ the
national security council and
constitutionalist experts was charged
with drafting the constitution it stated
the democratic and secular nature of the
turkish state confirmed the role of the
supreme military organ as the protector
of social order and expanded the powers
of the government and the president of
the republic the new electoral law then
set the threshold for entering
parliament at 10 percent so that in 1983
only three parties competed for seats
the people's party the nationalist party
and the motherland party the latter was
supported by the brotherhoods and
founded by turgot ozal who won 45
percent of the seats and became the
ruling party azzal's party succeeded in
embodying the turkish islamic synthesis
i mentioned bringing together the
military the brotherhoods and the small
and medium business class however
persistent economic backwardness
combined with the corruption and
inefficiency in the state began to
foster the emergence of the welfare
party founded by herbacan in 1987 and in
which a young erdogan was beginning to
make his mark the party wasn't driven by
any particular ideology but through a
team of economists tried to come up with
the best solutions to the problem of the
broken state finances it was an effort
that paid off as in the 1994 local
government elections the party wanted
more than 20 municipalities including
istanbul where erdogan was elected mayor
and in the july 1996 general elections
erbachan crowned his dream of becoming
prime minister but before long erbachan
would be way over his head as
conservative policies implemented by his
local administrators began to anger the
military these included plans to build
the mosque in istanbul staksim square a
place symbolic of the western way of
life and the desire to convert the
former saint sofia basilica into a
mosque another symbol of turkish secular
tradition since it had been turned into
a museum in 1934 by the will of bataturk
himself in addition contacts between the
welfare party and other middle eastern
islamic groups such as the palestinian
hamas the muslim brotherhood in egypt
and the algerian islamic salvation front
were putting the party in a bad light in
the eyes of the military and here we
come to the fourth coup of 1997 also
called the postmodern coupe because it
was implemented without bloodshed with
irbachan banned from political life
accused of stealing public funds and
inciting religious hate the welfare
party was dismantled and in its place
was born the following year the virtue
party into which the young erdogan
joined even though shortly before he had
been sentenced to 10 months in prison
and given his excellent record as mayor
of istanbul it's not surprising that
much of the population considered his
detention and injustice that would have
made him even more charming anyway of
the originally planned 10 months erdogan
served only four since in 2001 the
turkish constitutional court granted
amnesty to virtue party members who had
been banned from public office at that
point the party split into two fronts
the conservative wing of the islamic
metrics and the wing of the so-called
innovators the young moderate reformists
of which erdogan became the leader
founding the justice and development
party on august 14 of that year in the
november 3 2002 elections the akp became
the first party with 34.3 percent of the
vote but for some reasons that i won't
go into here erdogan had to lead from
behind the scenes letting his loyal
right-hand man abdullah ghoul replace
him as prime minister the akp on the
strength of its policy proposals aimed
at reviving the country's economic
situation hit by the 2001 crisis and
rising inflation would set up a muslim
government inspired by european
democracies but with the sun islamic
emphasis as ghul himself said although
some of us are religiously oriented
individuals we don't want to be defined
as a religious party we want to prove
that a muslim-majority country can be
democratic transparent and compatible
with the modern world major achievements
in the early 2000s including economic
growth of five percent annually
diversification of foreign trade and an
aid program for the poorer sections of
the population projected turkey into the
role of original power making it a
viable candidate for entry into the
european union so much so that
negotiations reopened as early as
october 2005. dear erdogan if last year
you hadn't confined ursula fonder lion
to that little couch maybe your flag
would also be in brussels today
jokes aside internally the reform of the
national security council was important
remember the supreme military organ
which was downgraded to an advisory
organ thus lessening the military's grip
on institutions in short a series of
achievements that led the akp to prevail
in the july 22 2007 elections with as
many as
46.6 percent of votes in favor
corresponding to 341 seats but on
balance the most important achievement
for the turkish leader was that of
having succeeded in getting abdullah
ghul elected to the position of
president of the republic which had in
fact consolidated his power over the
opposition the situation that had been
created however was a harbinger of a
dangerous authoritarian drift because
the government would be able to push
through laws bordering on constitutional
legitimacy without the head of state
casting any kind of veto starting in
2008 a number of events threatened to
compromise the prime minister's career
forever first and foremost the law
restoring the veil for women in
universities almost caused the party
closure for anti-like activities
according to the dossier submitted by
the chief prosecutor of the turkish
supreme court the rescue came when the
constitutional court called to rule on
the issue initially declared the law
contrary to the constitution but a few
months later reversed itself on public
interest grounds then it was the turn of
the prime minister's very strong
reaction against the members of the
organicon an alleged chemist-style
secret organization composed mainly of
senior army officials established with
the aim of overthrowing the government
and seizing power in a coup however an
affair that remains unclear to this day
with many accusing erdogan himself of
organizing everything to dispose of his
political opponents a 2016 ruling would
partially confirm these fears by
releasing most of those convicted
finally it was in may 2013 that there
was a harsh crackdown on
environmentalist protests against the
construction of a shopping mall in the
green area of genji park near taxing
square on that occasion police
intervened against the protesters using
tear gas and water cannons the media and
newspapers loyal to the government tried
to cover up the news but this caused the
event to resonate even more through
social networks such as facebook and
twitter which were blacked out anyway
the turbulent situation that had been
created was not enough to undermine the
popularity of erdogan who have increased
the three-term limit and unable to run
again for the leadership of the
government run for the presidency of the
republic in 2014 and one with 52 of the
votes in favor at that point the new
turkey project desired by the president
to require the annihilating the last
internal opponent still capable of
challenging him i'm referring to that
fetullah gulen who had long ago helped
him get rid of the catalysts and who
after the gezi park affair had instead
obstructed him his brotherhood let's
remember that he's met was from them on
branded as terrorists and targeted by
government forces the democratic values
that had brought the ruling party to
prominence back in 2002 had been
betrayed with a society sharply divided
between supporters and opponents of the
regime and the president with little
tolerance for his enemies frequent was
the use of article 299 of the turkish
panel code which provided for
imprisonment for all those who offended
the president of the republic a measure
that among other things in 2021 was
declared by the european court of human
rights to be detrimental to freedom of
expression the authoritarian drift was
so obvious that even within erdogan's
own party scorched earth had been made a
few years earlier the genji park affair
had caused the removal of loyalist
ghouls and in may 2016 trusted prime
minister ahmet tabotogul was also
removed due to differences in political
views and replaced by bin ali ildrim
boiling tensions erupted on that friday
evening july 15 2016 when a reporter
from state tv trt began reading a
lengthy statement from the coupe
plotters announcing the seizure of power
at the same time the military had
occupied the southern bridges over the
bosphorus in istanbul and two jets flew
over the city spreading terror among the
population erdogan declared in a live
video feed made from his smartphone that
he had survived the attack and called
for citizens to take to the streets to
defend democracy it was hours of terror
in ankara the parliamentary headquarters
was hard hit by the air force and
reduced to a pile of rubble but by the
next morning it was clear that the coup
had failed as army units still loyal to
the president managed to restore the
status quo even today it's difficult to
say who organized the coup at first
aronstein claimed that it was some
departments of the first and second
armies that carried it out along with
the support of elements of the air force
navy and coast guard another article by
political scientists vanta cornell
asserted instead that had been the work
of an unlikely alliance between old
style chemists and gulenists anyway the
casualties were about 240 civilians and
a few military personnel nothing
compared to those who die or be forced
to flee because of the government's
harsh reaction one thing is certain that
was indeed the golden opportunity to
wipe out all the main opponents and more
in fact gulen was blamed as the
architect of the coup backed by the cia
quick parenthesis remember that the last
period of the war in syria had brought
relations between russia and turkey
closer together meeting with a lot of
criticism from the united states after
that a state of emergency was declared
and not only the sectors of the military
and civil service involved in the coup
were affected but also those with whom
in the previous 15 years of rule the
party had had to come to terms in order
to secure power i leave you with the
detailed account of the various arrests
and dismissals that followed at that
point this would have been the icing on
the cake to lay hands on the
constitution with reform and move the
country toward the strong
presidentialism inspired by the french
model the group had caused the main
opposition forces to express solidarity
with the president and show willingness
to consider their proposed
constitutional reform however the quorum
needed to pass the amendments wasn't
reached and it was appropriate to go
through a referendum on april 16 2017
erdogan won with just
51.41
a victory that among other things was
criticized both by domestic oppositions
which accused the government of
electoral fraud and by the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
and the council of europe it was an
outcome that reflected the deep internal
rift in the country where erdogan's
legitimacy was slowly being challenged
by a general climate of protest over
arrests and repression by the
authorities that went far beyond those
belonging to fetal aguilance
organization it was very difficult for
the oppositions to work because at the
first mistake they risked being branded
as gulenists which over time has become
synonymous with terrorists today's
turkey which will celebrate the 100th
anniversary of the birth of the republic
in 2023 has its leadership a president
far away from the figure the father of
the turks envisioned of the catalyst the
six arrows very few remain intact and
among them it's clear that secularism is
no longer among the features of the
turkish state but still the political
involution we are witnessing has been
countered by economic growth such that
the country has become a major regional
power that was at least until the most
recent monetary policies led to the
devaluation of the turkish lira
culminating in the currency crisis of
2021 and the consequent rise in
inflation generating the risk of
stagnation in the economy due to the
rising cost of living and falling
internal demand all of this would also
impact the degree of discontent so much
so that impulse approval ratings toward
the erdogan's actions would have dropped
from 55.8 percent in march 2020 to 38.6
at the end of 2021 the lowest percentage
in recent years even lower than in early
2019 when dissatisfaction with the
performance of the economy had caused
the erdogan to lose control of istanbul
and ankara in local elections but it's
good to stop here for today i thank you
all for your attention and i will see
you in the next video ciao